everybody dog-walker here this is my
review of Zootopia again Rob wasn't able
to make this one ah but I went and I saw
it today and this movie's getting like
mad go to reviews like I think right now
it's at 98 percent on Rotten Tomatoes
that's insane there's totally nuts
um so I'm wondering like cuz I saw the
previews it look cute and whatever but I
mean like best forget 98% I'm like what
the hell is in this movie that got 98% I
was so curious I went I saw this movie
and um it's good it's uh as probably a
lot of people and mentioned it's kind of
like Disney's version of crash um the
the one that's all about prejudice and
diversity and stuff and that's good uh
it's it's a good movie it's one of those
things where I think because I hear like
ever since I was a little kid I hear
these stories all the time about how
prejudice is bad and you shouldn't do it
and you know should be open-minded and
everything it's one of those things
where it's like I know it and at the
very beginning of this bill to make it
clear that's what's gonna be about and I
just Amelie cannot it what oh it's um
that kind of movie okay alright and I'm
hoping maybe they'll do something kind
of new with it and they do uh not only
does it talk about prejudice and
diversity and such it talks about it in
a way that's very relevant today so it
is very very clever um I think for me
because with these kind of stories even
when they're good and this is like this
is kind of my prejudice even when these
stories are good I feel like because I
know the moral and because it's gonna
focus a lot on this uh it starts to lose
me a little bit and I always feel like
it has to be a little funnier or a
little more creative if it's gonna keep
me invested and keep me to really like
it
and it is my n it is clever um but
there's a lot of moments where it's like
okay we're just going to take like 10
solid minutes and we are going to hammer
this in
then we'll have like maybe two minutes
of like a really good comedy and clever
writing and just great jokes and
characters and stuff and then another
ten minutes where we're really gonna
hammer this in up but the way they
hammer then again is relevant today and
what pisses me off about this movie is
that I kinda have to say it's brilliant
and it's really great because this is
one of those things where you think like
oh well come on isn't this heavy-handed
don't people know this is you know not
right and all this stuff and it Trump's
in the lead and it's like shit damn it
now we gotta say yes this is relevant
because you know look what the buddies
sing Trump supporters but prejudice is
bad it's like god dammit it so pisses me
off that this is still such as big an
issue as it is I mean it's never going
away it's like anything it's like
prejudice sexism racism you know all
this it's never going away
human nature all that stuff and they
refer to that - you know our basic
en or you know this is our horrible
inner savage nature and stuff but it's
such a shame to see that it is as big as
it is and I don't know what it should
supporters
nobody knows any Trump supporters nobody
knows where these people are coming from
I think it's just like yes or this
civilized world that's you know just
trying to you know evolve as the movie
says and you know get better and then
it's just like out of these caves out of
there duck dynasty fan clubs or
something they kind of crawl out and
they crawl out in big numbers and like
the rest of America it's like we really
didn't know they were there we had no
idea this was a joke this started off as
a joke so it that is relevant to this
because uh while this movie does seem
very heavy-handed even though it's done
clever uh it's something that sadly is
relevant um so I guess what I'm getting
at with that is that this is it kind of
depends on what you're looking for
because if you're like me and you know
this is going to be the focus it's like
well okay it is there enough clever
writing and characters and stuff there
is for a good
film and it is good uh but like I said
this moral if you already know this
moral if you're already open-minded if
you're already like you know you don't
want to keep whatever the immigrants out
and make America great again stuff
you're gonna get this uh and it's a lot
of shoving this in your face and it is
smart because it's tying into the
different animals and predators and
stereotypes and they make fun of them
but it's mostly trying to be very
dramatic with it um so it's one of those
things where if you want to see a movie
like that if you want to see a film
really hammer in what bullshit that is
you're gonna love it and I think a lot
of people are sick of seeing all these
Trump supporters and they are sick of
seeing all this prejudice you know what
would you turn on the news that's like
here's the latest prejudice bullshit you
know it's it's still around it's still
relevant not at all saying it isn't I'm
saying that uh for a film like this I
was kind of expecting even more comedy
even more kind of a fun clever writing
and wordplay and visuals and stuff but
there's there's a lot of people just
sort of sitting around talking about how
much it sucks to be a bunny a fox a
predator-prey whatever there's there's a
lot of that in this uh and if that's not
your thing
um I think you'll still like it it is a
good movie I just don't know if you'll
get into it as much it's like everyone
else is getting into it but could I mean
like the show we went to packed house I
mean kids all over the place and the
kids were liking it okay but they were
gonna kick the see a little bit they're
kind of turning on their phones a little
bit there's trying to talk to the mom
and dad they were getting antsy a little
bit and then eventually near the end
they throw in a little bit of action and
adventure and stuff um and there is
creativity to it Zootopia in general is
a very cool-looking place uh and there's
a lot of cool designs and the animals
and the buildings there's different
parts of the city which is really cool
there's like a winter part there's a
rainforest part on
I kind of want more I want to see more
of the designs the best part of the
movie is just the train going through
Zootopia and showing what it looks like
and I kind of wish even though they do
go to these parts you know I think they
go to every single part which is good
they don't stay in one location um I
kind of wanted to see even more like of
the designs and the layouts and stuff at
beyond that train ride it's not like you
never see it but you know that the focus
is gonna be on the characters and I
don't know there's a scene near the end
where there's like a train chase which
I'm a sucker for train chases I love
them I don't know if I've ever seen up
to a train Chase uh and this one's good
too but it's one of those things where
it's like kind of wrapped up pretty
quickly I'm thinking like man couldn't
they go through more different parts of
the world or whatever uh the other great
part in is they they go through this
little mouse village it's like a bunny
and a weasel and they're chasing chair
through this mouse village and it's
great cuz everybody's really tiny and
tiny buildings and they're going around
like Giants man I wanted more of that I
wanted so much more of that uh and what
I got is a fair amount it's a good
amount um but it's not a great amount
it's not 98 percent great to me um but I
think I might just be kind of in the
minority on that uh I think it's one of
those things where a lot of people are
kind of sick of what's going on right
now with all this prejudice and such and
I think this movies coming out pretty
much it's just the right time and it
does capture the frustration it captures
the reasons why I'm much better than
crash dog um it it actually really does
sum up this stuff very well and makes it
very relevant to today um but yeah if
you're thinking like you're gonna get
some really funny silly comedy that's
going to be really fast and throwing a
lot of jokes at you and stuff um it's
that at times but it's mostly this story
about prejudice and diversity so if
that's what you're looking for which
apparently a lot of people are and
nothing wrong with it at all I mean it's
it's good it is relevant um it's just
for me I I find myself whenever I see a
story like that I'm like okay it's it's
gonna be this
all right let's let's do it you know
it's fine it's not like a wire revealed
story or a you know save the rain for a
story where it's just as soon as it
starts you're like oh fuck no please you
know it's not like that I mean because
this stuff does still happen all the
time it's always gonna be relevant um
but the the way they show it I thought
could have been a little funnier and
maybe that's what I'm looking for I was
looking for more comedy I think because
the characters are fine and the timings
decent uh there's one or two jokes that
go by really quick that I kind of can't
took me a minute like she's talking
about she's doing math while talking
about talking to his Fox and she says
we're really good at multiplying bunnies
are it's like okay that took me a second
I got it but my my wife explained that
joke to me because she got the bunny
saying it very very fast and it says
about 20 other things and then that was
one of the lines and she's like oh
that's pretty good the bunny's
multiplying oh wait yes took me a minute
so once or twice there's a line like
that that goes by really quick and again
I think as I am spoiled by comedies like
Hot Fuzz and stuff like that I really do
want comedy be really quick and trying
all sorts of different things and new
things it's not that this isn't trying
new things it's that I I think I'm just
kind of spoiled and I want even more um
and I don't know I guess it's about when
I saw the trailer this is about what I
thought I'd get um maybe not quite as
much the prejudice and diversity stuff
but you know I'm glad that's in there
too um you know it is kind of the nail
on the head but it's you know why like I
said I mean we kind of right now where
some people need to hear an anime buddy
saying hey this obvious thing that you
should know when you're 2 years old you
know this this is still bad you know
kind of thing um so I like it it's a
good film it does have good characters
uh it's it's hard for me to say great
just personally but I do know it is very
very clever uh in talking about this and
in the diver
city and Prejudice and it's like the two
words I've said the most throughout this
box sorry um but it is a good film for
me I don't know if I connected as much
to how great it is but I do know that
the set up and everything is it is a
very very clever setup and it does take
advantage of it for the for toffee as
metaphor pretty much um and it works
it's good I don't think I got into as
much as everyone else did but I still
recommend it you're gonna get some lash
you're gonna get uh you know some clever
symbolism and such but yeah so if you
saw the trailer and said oh that might
be cute you know at the very least
you'll find it that I can't see anybody
watching this being like that was shit
that was no thought no effort put into
it at all clearly there's a lot and a
lot of it works um so yeah I think it's
pretty much a good review for the movie
I can't see anyone saying that's a bad
movie it'll be at the worst it'll be
okay at the best it'll be phenomenal
because so many people are saying how
phenomenal this movie is and it's not a
big movie to see that way uh like I say
it just didn't make quite as big a
connection to me but what the hell do I
know I looked 34 year old white suburban
Knight makes his living on the Internet
look at this movies that faith for me uh
so yeah it's a it is good I do
definitely recommend uh checking it out
so that's about it I will talk to you
later take care